pronto pronto via parri ciao dimmi
vorrei qualche tuttavia tutto l'anno
lynch aveva provato a secondo me per un
periodo cioè quasi riuscita a fregarci
fatto sta che dopo sette libri che ti
leggi o sei un cretino o qualche domanda
a parte la maco e sicure queste cui
ripeto in questa specie di high school
musical della magia man hasan doccia e
la somma è fatta e con questa lezione
bene imparato tutti gli incantesimi che
i nuovi mani possiamo fare
oddio di mieri adesso che c'è chi è che
ti rompe le palle un altro mostro brass
ultima corsa della io faccio gli
spaghetti qualcuno professore voglio
solo il milan le cose ma sono solo
questi i tantissimi dobbiamo imparare i
ferri nei peccati avere solo duemila
anni che stiamo facendo incantesimo ne
so pure rotto un attimo è ormai lungo la
bacchetta 6 come bollette c'è alcuno ok
dai e su collabora che io qui non ce la
faccio più a stacco voi sa che se dono
più [ __ ] del al professore però
abbiamo saltato e un capitolo importante
oddio e quale quello delle seguire
r mi dispiace che non esistono
incantesimi per quelle cose prof
com'è possibile versione finiti da
ognuno sui dormitori eri se tu ti senti
solo mettiti ad accarezzarti la civiltà
ok è possibile insomma voglio dire cioè
imparano 2000 incantesimi su come spegne
al sedicente per carità fate quello che
vi pare fatele male continuate a giocare
soldatini che si ammazzano occupa alcuni
alle bacchette cavoli mostre divertitevi
però di
che awards no niente ceretti inguinali
indolori e potete fa rimozione
dell'arduo allungamento del pene che
erotico sessuali che solamente non agi
adv offrire no silente l'unico e se te
ne avesse queste chicche tutti gli
alpini stronzi che stanno lì a fare
incantesimi ancora che combatte contro
l'arbor nemo dai ma almeno dico gandalf
che si fuma valere una pipa chiamalo
scemo se faceva bond da una gattina sera
che si divertano ma almeno se nessuno
per l'insegnante degli affari tuoi
esperimenti franti voi veniste large
ment piaceri sorani circoncisione allora
questo e non facciamo gli ipocriti
adesso lo salutate il mio coinquilino
che da qui ancora più orribile ma è tipo
tre mesi che sta lì cioè nel senso la
mattina scompare però poi addio la sera
ciccia fuori